ça va très bien merci olivier paccaud
bonjour françois xavier bellamy merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin vous êtes député européen nous
avons nombre des républicains et on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
pascal jalabert qui n'ont rejoint pascal
du groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france on va parler des
républicains dans quelques instants
françois-xavier bellamy mais d'abord
l'actualité ce sont ces législatives
hier en allemagne et on a vu ce sont les
sociaux-démocrates qui arrive en tête
d'une courte tête la gauche donc et la
cdo la droite conservatrice les
conservateurs le parti d'angela merkel
qui arrive donc derrière et qui
reconnaît un résultat décevant pour vous
aussi c'est une déception c'est un recul
de la droite européenne bien sûr c'est
une déception cela étant dit il faut
quand même se rendre compte de la
performance que vous présente le fait
qu'après 16 ans aux responsabilités la
cdo arrive effectivement à un point
derrière le parti social-démocrate
maintenant s'ouvre et cela a été
largement commentée par vos confrères
une période qui va être décisive en
allemagne parce que personne ne sait
encore quelle sera la la coalition qui
va qui va gouverner les allemands ont
une culture de la coalition qui est très
différente de notre propre culture
démocratique de d'une majorité et d'une
opposition qui qui sont directement le
résultat des urnes donc il ya encore un
peu de temps pour voir comment les
choses vont se structurer mais peut-être
une observation à la veille de notre
propre année présidentielle le schéma
qu'on nous décrivait comme étant
désormais le nouveau clivage celui qui
opposerait d'un côté les les
progressistes de l'autre côté les
populistes ce schéma en réalité n'existe
nulle part ailleurs que dans l'esprit
des manuels macron et de ceux qui avec
en marche cherche à faire vivre une
sorte de clivage qui n'en est pas un le
vrai clivage qui structurent la vie
démocratique partout en europe dans le
monde occidental c'est le clivage entre
la gauche et la droite et on l'a vu
encore dans cette élection fédérale en
allemagne on voit très bien que le débat
démocratique est structurée par cette
nécessaire opposition par cette
alternative indispensable entre d'un
côté en allemand le parti
social-démocrate et de l'autre côté la
laddh cd ou la cs ou c'est ce qui se
joue aussi au parlement européen vous
parliez de temps juste de temps
effectivement cette coalition la risque
de prendre du temps on parle même d'une
échéance avant noël c'est à dire quand
même dans deux trois mois est ce que ça
vous inquiète cette période
d'incertitude qui s'ouvre en allemagne
est ce que ça vous inquiète pour la
stabilité de l'union européenne non ça
fait partie de la vie politique
allemande et il n'ya pas d'instabilité
particulière en allemagne encore une
fois on a une chance élire qui va
quitter ses fonctions après 16 ans aux
responsabilités je pensais une stabilité
qui ferait rêver n'importe quel
gouvernants français donc ce serait
absurde de parler d'une instabilité
allemande en revanche je crois que ça
nous renvoie à une question pour nous
parce qu'on peut commenter la vie
politique allemande mais moi je suis un
responsable politique français et j'ai
été élu par des français pour les
représenter au parlement européen ce que
je constate c'est que nous avons un défi
majeur qui est de réussir à faire
entendre la voix de la france dans les
institutions européennes
les allemands n'ont pas de difficulté à
défendre les priorités de leur pays dans
le débat européen
et ils ont bien raison de le faire et
c'est nous qui sommes bien trop souvent
aux abonnés absents sur sur des sujets
qui sont pourtant majeur je pense par
exemple au sujet d'énergie qui vont être
décisifs dans les mois et les années qui
viennent on voit que les prix de
l'énergie aujourd'hui pour les français
ne cessent d'augmenter pour beaucoup de
citoyens en europe sous l'effet de
politiques et écologiques qui me
paraissent complètement myope est
totalement aberrant au regard de la
compétition mondiale eh bien il me
semble que nous devons dans le débat qui
entoure par exemple la taxonomie dont on
parle enfin un peu nous défendons ce
sujet depuis deux ans défendre la place
du mix énergétique français défendre le
lac l'air
et c'est là le grand paradoxe de ce
gouvernement c'est que c'est le en même
temps perpétuelle bruno le maire à paris
dit il y a seulement quelques semaines
que ceci est un sujet important ça fait
deux ans qu'on tire la sonnette d'alarmé
mais pendant ce temps là la vérité c'est
que l'administration française qui
négocie à bruxelles c'est celle de
madame pompili qui ne se cache pas
d'être anti nucléaire donc il ya un
sujet majeur c'est comment voulez vous
construire une politique énergétique
crédible quand vous dites que vous tenez
à l'énergie nucléaire et que
simultanément vous voulez fermer de
manière anticipée des centrales
nucléaires pour dépendre du coup de plus
en plus du gaz du charbon
parce que c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on à fermer
fessenheim lorsque ce gouvernement à
fermer fessenheim il nous a rendus plus
dépendants d'une énergie importées qui
est produite avec du gaz et du charbon
donc on perd sur tous les tableaux et
cette espèce de fragilité qui n'est des
incohérences de la politique du
gouvernement aujourd'hui elle doit
absolument avoir une fin cette année et
j'espère que l'élection présidentielle
sera l'occasion de donner à notre pays
un gouvernement enfin solide claire dans
ses or c'est cela qui fera peser la voix
de la france
défend ses intérêts bien sûr mais c'est
une certitude c'est tuer évidemment un
problème de long terme le gouvernement
n'est pas responsable de tout et ça fait
trop longtemps qu'on a peu investi pas
assez investi sur le débat européen mais
ce que je constate avec ce gouvernement
c'est que au fond nous le voyons sur ce
sujet d'énergie c'est un exemple comme
sur tant d'autres la france ne défend
pas ses intérêts elle est souvent la
seule à défendre ce que nous regardons
comme un espèce d'intérêt européen je
prends un exemple tout simple le grand
emprunt dont on nous a vanté les mérites
cet emprunt européen et va en réalité
coûté plus cher à la france qu'ils ne
l'aidera aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous
pouvons toucher 40 milliards d'euros
dans le cadre du plan de relance demain
nous devons rembourser plus de 60
milliards donc pour le contribuable
français c'est évidemment une mauvaise
affaire à un moment où par ailleurs la
france n'a aucun problème de financement
sur les marchés et ça c'est un exemple
de plus que en prétendant être un grand
européen emmanuel macron joue en réalité
contre les priorités qui devraient être
celles de la france et qu'ils doivent
être aussi celle de la france pour l'
équilibre général de l'union européenne
parce que l'union européenne ce et j'en
suis convaincu un projet qui peut nous
permettre de nous renforcer dans la
mondialisation mais aujourd'hui c'est
une certitude c'est chacun est une
fragilisée est ce que finalement
emmanuel macron il n'a pas raison de
faire passer l'union européenne d'abord
est-ce que la france ne sera pas plus
forte si l'union européenne est plus pop
non l'union européenne ne sera forte que
si elle démontre citoyens des pays qui
la constituent qu'elles renforcent leur
état dans le monde qui se dessine je ne
crois pas du tout à une union européenne
qui remplacerait les états je ne crois
pas à une union européenne qui consiste
qui consisterait à transférer notre
souveraineté à l'échelle européenne
s'est elle eu le mot de la république en
marche pendant la l'élection européenne
je ne crois pas à cette illusion
fédéraliste et la vérité c'est que si on
regarde la manière dont l'allemagne se
comporte l'allemagne ne crois pas du
tout à une union européenne qui
consisterait à abolir les intérêts de
chaque pays et est d'ailleurs ce serait
absurde nous sommes une alliance de
démocratie mais chacune de nos
démocraties vie a son propre agenda et
nous pouvons nous renforcer si nous
arrivons justement à construire un
dialogue dans lequel chacun se fasse
respecter et entendre et on va en parler
sur la question de défense notamment
pascal oui alors la défense européenne
ça reste un leurre on la voit pas venir
chaque fois il ya quelqu'un qui dit ah
oui mais bon et la france c'est toujours
un peu seul comment arriver à convaincre
nos partenaires à les convaincre de quoi
c'est la première question moi je n'ai
jamais cru contrairement au président de
la république je n'ai jamais cru à la
fiction d'une armée européenne
jamais il n'y aura pas demain d'armée
européenne et pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que d'abord ce serait une
réalité totalement contraire à la
démocratie pas de décision plus
importante pour un responsable politique
que celui d'envoyer en opération des
soldats qui vont exposer leurs vies qui
vont risquer leur vie qu'ils vont donner
la mort et qui vont risquer la mort et
donc on ne peut pas imaginer que demain
ceux ci se fasse dans un cadre
démocratique qui ne soit pas celui de
nos nations qui sont le cadre légitime
dans lequel sont restés sous le
parapluie de l'otan non ça veut dire
qu'on peut faire beaucoup en europe pour
progresser sur les sujets de défense
mais pas dans le sens de ses illusions
et moi j'ai travaillé par exemple au
parlement européen pour vous parler de
résultats concrets pour faire aboutir
enfin le fonds européen de défense dont
je suis le rapporteur pour mon groupe le
fonds européen de défense et plusieurs
milliards d'euros 8 milliards sur la
première programmation pour l'industrie
de défense en europe et là dessus on
peut faire beaucoup
on voit à quel point la compétition
mondiale est rude et on voit que
l'europe se ferait mieux respectés si
nous étions capables de construire en
commun des matériels qui puisse nous
donner les moyens de notre autonomie
stratégique demain pour aller au mali on
ne devrait pas avoir besoin de demander
aux américains l'autorisation d'employer
les matériels qu'on leur a acheté c'est
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui finalement
qu'est ce qu'on fait au mali france
ce week-end la force européenne la force
takouba elle a du mal à prendre son
envol qu'est-ce qu'on fait du coup
est-ce qu'on accélère le calendrier de
retrait est ce qu on maintient nos
troupes au mali quitte à être seule est
ce que la france allait pas laissé seul
par ses partenaires européens
permettez-moi d'abord de dire à quel
point je crois nous nous nous devons
témoigner notre reconnaissance au
caporal-chef maxime blasco qui
effectivement a donné sa vie pour la
france au mali
vendredi matin qu'il était le terme est
parfois galvaudée mais un véritable
héros de ce que nous savons de lui il
incarne justement ce donc que la france
fait aujourd'hui
au prix du sang de ses hommes pour la
sécurité de notre pays mais aussi de
toute l'europe menacés par l'islamisme
la question de savoir comment renforcer
notre engagement se pose et je crois
qu'il est temps en effet que les
européens se rendre compte qu'ils
doivent à la france une solidarité plus
grande pour l'engagement qu'elle a
aujourd'hui sur le terrain pour la
sécurité de tous mais je crois que c'est
indécent d'avoir un débat sur la
pertinence de cet engagement au moment
justement où certains sont en train de
combattre et certains sont en train de
mourir et certains justement qu'ils nous
disent l'urgence de ce combat
l'islamisme aujourd'hui s'ils gagnent au
mali on l'a vu très bien en libye on l'a
vu très bien en irak on l'a vu très bien
en syrie si l'islamisme gagne au mali
alors c'est nous tous ici en france qui
seront en danger donc nous devons
poursuivre le combat hors calendrier de
retrait progressif est appelé par
emmanuel macron c'est le bon pour vous
je pense qu'il faut avoir une réflexion
stratégique mais qui ne se déroule pas
dans le dans le le moment d'un d'un
deuil nécessaire parce que encore une
fois ce serait vraiment indécent mais le
plus important encore une fois ça n'est
pas seulement le combat contre
l'islamisme au sahel au mali loin de nos
frontières le plus important c'est
savoir si nous sommes capables de mener
aussi ce combat en france et je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose de scandaleux à
mesure et l'incohérence entre l'héroïsme
de ceux qui se risquent pour vaincre
l'islamisme loin de nos frontières pour
notre sécurité et la lâcheté avec
laquelle nous traitons ce défi encore
trop souvent en france et en europe je
pense par exemple à la complaisance que
certains ont avec l'idéologie islamiste
à la facilité avec laquelle nous
acceptons que parfois et je regarde sur
la question européenne que parfois même
des fonds européens sont utiles soient
utilisés florence bergeaud-blackler
keane chercheuse l'a montré encore tout
récemment des fonds européens sont
utilisées par des officines proche des
frères musulmans pour pouvoir financer
des programmes qui sous couvert de lutte
contre la discrimination sous couvert de
défense d'un agenda intersectionnelle
sont en réalité la porte ouverte à cette
idéologie de mort et donc si certains
vous parlez de la complaisance de
certains vis-à-vis des islamistes qui
sont certains mais je vous le redis avec
un mélange de naïveté et d'auto
aveuglement des institutions
d'aidé des forces politiques
mais je vous citais à l'instant
l'exemple de la commission européenne
des programmes de recherche de la
commission européenne sont utilisés
aujourd'hui par dd des officines par des
agences qui sont manifestement gangrené
par l'idéologie islamiste aujourd'hui
encore dans notre pays comment se
fait-il que nous n'ayons pas une action
plus radicale plus déterminée contre les
contre les mosquées qui propagent
l'islamisme dans nos quartiers en france
le gouvernement se félicite de fermer de
temps en temps une de trois mosquées
islamistes mais on est très loin du
compte et tous les français le mesure on
est très loin du compte quand des
collègues professeurs me raconte combien
il devient difficile d'enseigner à des
élèves qui sont quotidiennement
endoctrinés dans la mosquée qu'il
fréquente chaque jour l'école de la
république doit faire face à des
adversaires idéologiques que nous
n'osons pas affronter je crois que
malheureusement on peut dire que le
sacrifice de maxime blasco n'est pas
n'est pas honoré comme il comme il le
faudrait à propos à propos de défense on
a quand même je te crise du souverain
l'europe a tardé à soutenir la france
est en un certain alliés bon le danemark
par exemple c'est vraiment des alliés
dans cette histoire comment comment
sortir est-ce qu'il fallait être
beaucoup plus sévère avec les états unis
avec l'australie oui on voit très bien
que la france est effectivement trop
isolé et on revient à ce que je disais à
l'instant le sujet c'est comment est-ce
que la france réussit à se faire
entendre son nom l'otan comme un fait de
gaulle il faut c'est clair réviser la
manière dont se structurent notre
partenariat stratégique avec le temps et
surtout le rééquilibrer moi je ne crois
pas que sortir de l'otan soit la
meilleure option parce que sortir de
l'otan ça veut dire aussi justement se
marginaliser se mettre à l'écart et
s'isoler mais comment réussit-on à se
faire entendre à l'intérieur de l'otan
comment se faire entendre à l'intérieur
de l'union européenne voilà de vraies
questions lorsque cet été l'été dernier
par dont le la turquie a menacé la grèce
et chypre en faisant rentrer des bateaux
militaires dans les autres territoires
yal de la grèce la france a envoyé des
frégates mais la france était seule à
réagir et emmanuel macron a eu une ayons
pas peur de lire le courage d'engager un
bras de fer avec la turquie mais il l'a
fait d'une manière qui est totalement
solitaire comment se fait il que nous
n'ayons pas été capable de faire
comprendre à nos partenaires
stratégiques les plus proches que la
turquie était un défi global pour notre
sécurité aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
laisser la france se trouvait de plus en
plus isolé et ceux qui aujourd'hui
disent que la france devrait sortir de
l'otan me semble-t-il ne prennent pas
assez en compte le fait que ce serait
pour nous l'occasion de sortir encore un
peu plus de la possibilité d'une forme
de rayonnement dans le jeu
géostratégique mondiale qui est en train
d'évoluer aujourd'hui de manière
absolument décision
maintenant parler de votre famille
politique ça y est les militants ont
tranché ils désigneront le candidat à la
présidentielle via un congrès uniquement
réservé aux militants des républicains
ce que c'est la bonne méthode pour vous
moi je regrette que nous ne soyons pas
passer par une primaire plus ouverte
parce que cette primaire plus ouverte
aurait permis sans aucun doute
d'associer tous les français qui
attendent de se voir représentés par
notre famille politique dans cette
élection qui vient mais c'est un fait
voilà en tous les cas ce qui comptait
pour moi c'est qu'il y ait un vrai débat
et que ce soit dans une primaire ou dans
un congrès il y aura un vrai débat il y
aura une élection et c'est je crois le
plus important parce que nous avons
besoin de ce débat de fond pour nous
présenter devant les français avec une
ligne qui soit claire en ayant fait un
choix qui soit claire et c'est ce qui
nous attend maintenant ça veut dire pour
vous il faut qu'ils aient des débats
télévisés par exemple entre les cinq
candidats il faut qu'ils aient il y aura
de toute évidence
des discussions un dialogue public qui
s'engagent pour pouvoir justement
discuter de pas seulement de la personne
encore une fois on a trop souvent
tendance à aller immédiatement vers les
questions de personne mais c'est le prix
de ces lignes c'est une présidentielle
donc c'est normal que personne parmi les
cinq et avec la rihanna killer qui pour
vous que vous auriez dû soutenir ouais
je viens de vous le dire il faut qu'un
débat s'engage d'abord je ne sais pas
s'il y aura cinq candidats s'il y en
aura plus y en aura - on ne sait pas
encore exactement le le périmètre de ce
débat et puis deuxièmement il faut que
le dialogue ait lieu
ce congrès il ne faut pas être encartée
au républicain manifestement sur jacques
bertrand la mairie pécresse vonvon
moi je ne vois pas de 2,2 je ne vois pas
ce qui empêcherait ça et je pense encore
une fois qu'on a besoin du dialogue le
plus ouvert et le et le plus large pour
pouvoir justement faire le choix le plus
fort possible à la veille de cette
élection de cette élection si importante
et je crois qu'il est la condition c'est
partager les valeurs de la droite et du
sens pour vous ils partagent les valeurs
de la droite et du centre il peut être
candidat à ce contrat qui d'autre que
les électeurs de droite peuvent le dit
c'est de le trancher je voudrais juste
resituer le débat et dire l'ampleur de
l'enjeu je crois que nous sommes à la
veille d'une élection vital pour
l'avenir de notre pays vital parce que
nous le voyons bien sur les sujets
économiques industrielles notre pays est
en plein décrochage vital parce que le
rayonnement de la france à
l'international en europe est en train
d'être durablement fragilisé vital parce
que rien n'a été résolu du problème de
notre système scolaire qui est le
problème qui conditionne notre avenir
vital parce que nous faisons face à ce
défi majeur que représente le fait que
les flux migratoires des dernières
années ont laissé se développer en
france une archipel isation qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui des gens vivent dans ce
pays grandissent dans ce pays sans se
reconnaître des liens les uns avec les
autres et c'est un défi de civilisation
qui nous attend donc on ne peut pas si
vous voulez on ne peut pas réduire
l'espace de la discussion comme si il
n'y avait pas ce sujet il y à un sujet
majeur et il faut l'affronter parler le
projet de programme mais qui doit le
porter est-ce qu'il faut d'ores et déjà
le préparer et puis dire au cogner à
tiens voilà ton programme ou bien
attendre d'avoir le candidat pour que
celui ci l'ait l'amour c'est ce qui a
déjà été fait et on a travaillé au sein
de deux des républicains au cours des
derniers mois autour de christian jacob
pour pouvoir structurer un projet il ya
quelques jours ont présenté une
proposition pour la politique européenne
des années qui viennent donc on est déjà
sur le fond en train de se structurer
pour avoir devant les français une
proposition d'alternance crédible et et
je crois que je me permets de le dire
que c'est la raison de mon engagement
dans cette famille politique c'est la
responsabilité de la droite parce que la
droite est la seule force politique qui
puisse représenter une alternance à
emmanuel macron la seule c'est donc elle
est en ordre de marche est ce qu
attendent par exemple 4 décembre pour
choisir notre candidat c'est pas trop
tard jean leonetti lui-même il disait
oui c'est un peu tard nous sommes le
seul parti à ne pas avoir encore deux
candidats identifiés oui je partage
l'avis de jean leonetti qui a fait un
travail remarquable pour préparer notre
famille politique à cette échéance et
moi je fais partie de ceux qui disaient
c'est vrai vous voyez je vous le dis
sans langue de bois je l ai déjà dit à
ce micro d'ailleurs j'avais partie de
ceux qui disaient que il aurait sans
doute fallu trancher le calendrier
plutôt pour que nous pion à voir a
raconté aux français la manière dont
nous allons nous organiser pour pouvoir
nous présenter à eux dans cette élection
mais c'est un fait non maintenant on est
effectivement en septembre il faut se
préparer à ce débat important décembre
n'est pas trop tard mais c'est vrai que
cela va exiger de notre famille
politique d'avoir une vraie dynamique
les élections régionales les élections
départementales ont montré que nous
étions capables de rassembler les
français que nous étions capables d'être
une force d'alternance plus maintenant
il faut nous préparer à avoir le
district man hulk rond eric zemmour
lequel est de droite et le maquereau
n'est pas de droite en tous les cas ça
c'est une
je m'arrête un instant sur ce point
parce que c'est fascinant qu'on nous
dise encore aujourd'hui après quatre ans
d'exercice de son mandat quel manuel
mâcon serait de droite d'une certaine
manière ça m'est égal ce qui compte pour
moi c'est la france mais enfin qu'on ne
nous fasse pas croire qu est venue de
maquereaux et de droite un président de
la république qui fait que les titres de
séjour diffusé aujourd'hui en france
n'ont jamais été aussi importants depuis
40 ans on a 400 mille entrées légales
dans ce pays depuis le début de ce
quinquennat un président de la
république qui a endetté la france comme
jamais même dans les trois années qui
ont précédé le coc vide la france est
endettée plus vite que pendant le
quinquennat de françois hollande un
président de la république est à ce
point à recentraliser a détruit toutes
les conditions de la subsidiarité et de
la responsabilisation des corps
intermédiaires qui a supprimé la taxe
d'habitation qui donc a asphyxié les
communes qui a tout concentrer dans les
pouvoirs d'un président jupitérien ce
président là n'est pas de droite un
président de la république qui méprise à
ce point les les libertés fondamentales
on l'a vu d'ailleurs à la manière dont
il revenait sur sa propre parole pendant
la crise du corona violences sur des
sujets qui sont fondamentaux non ce
président-là cléry la pâte et donc et
non je le dis parce que ça devient
presque
improbable d'entendre toujours dire
aujourd'hui bien quand emmanuel macron
en était au stade du discours on pouvait
se demander quelle politique qu'il
allait mener je n'ai jamais cru au
maquereau nice mais après quatre ans
quand même croire encore au maquereau
nisme ce serait
donc eric zemmour lui il a un discours
de droite on peut la pression peut ne
pas l'apprécier au contrôle et de la pré
saison mais encore une fois tu es ce
qu'ils estiment ce qui m'importe ce
n'est pas la question de la droite ce
qui m'importe c'est la question de la
france et je crois que pour que la
france même si vous partagez fois un
débat démocratique qui sont claires est
ce que vous partagez vous la vision de
la france je crois qu'eric zemmour a le
mérite de poser une question
fondamentale qui est celle justement de
la capacité que nous aurons de préserver
ce qui nous lie ce qui nous unit ce qui
fait que nous sommes français ce qui
fait que nous sommes français quelle que
soit d'ailleurs notre histoire quelle
que soit l'histoire de notre famille on
peut être pleinement français y compris
en étant issus de l'immigration récente
ça suppose précisément ce miracle qui ne
fonctionnent plus aujourd'hui de
l'assimilation celui par lequel on
rejoint une communauté de destin par une
culture partagée ça a été mon combat
comme professeur ça a été mon combat je
dirais comme quand j'ai très tentés de
travailler dans le domaine intellectuel
en publiant les déshérités je voulais
dire justement à quel point nous avons
besoin de cette culture commune pour
être capable de nouveau de faire vivre
notre vie démocratique notre vie sociale
de retrouver une civilité commune et
l'effondrement de la culture partagée
que que nous avions en commun ne peut
que s'accompagner de la montée de 7 des
civilisations de 7 ans sauvagement que
que je décrivais de dd 2014 donc c'était
les déshérités et que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui a des pudeurs de gazelle
pour pour reconnaître oui le diagnostic
il est il est fondamental et il faut le
faire sur le
choix du candidat c'est un bon signal
pour le rassemblement est-ce qu'il faut
que les centristes participe à la
désignation du candidat de la droite et
du centre moi je vous dis je regrette
qu'on n'ait pas eu une primaire plus
ouverte j'ai fait toute la campagne
européenne aux côtés d'hervé morin et
hervé morin a eu un courage une
constance une solidité dans dans sa
parole et dans son action que que
beaucoup de responsables
non pas je crois que
je crois qu'on aurait eu tout intérêt à
encore une fois à s'adresser de façon
très très ouverte à tous ceux qui
attendent que notre famille politique
représente une alternance et une
espérance pour la france dans quelques
mois mais maintenant voilà c'est ainsi
ça ne nous empêchera pas de de
travailler avec tous les français qui
souhaiteront porter avec nous cette
cette espérance dont nous avons
tellement besoin merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]